[Applaudissements]
et ça ça qu'on a décidé d'appeler ça un
gars une panacée regarde bien manger où
il n'ya pas fatou dans ce jeu est un peu
là guest maillage silence ça pousse
comme d'autres slip à les avoir agi de
places pour aller voir radar serait
dingue le 1er février
c'est un super cadeau des cours
ils ont même réussi à mal habillés laury
thilleman les enlève déjà tu as bien
fait de remettre ses huit passes que je
m'endormais devant désolante un t'as vu
ça sent un hacker crème ah j'adore ça
tue mais comme un temps où m la crème
sur ton zen assez bas
plusieurs couches et y en a d'autres qui
est la vraie d'être à ma place un outil
d attaque est inquiète
j'ai prendre un bain mais au bout du
rouleau ex giat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]